sie kennt liebt zum eislaufen
chinesische musik
vor 20 jahren hat der 76-jährige mit dem
training begonnen es hilft ihm seine
trauer zu verarbeiten
sein sohn verstarb schon sehr früh seine
frau vor zwei jahren
[Musik]
eiskunstlaufen ist ein unverzichtbarer
teil von mir es hat mein leben so
verändert klar vermisse ich meine
familie aber ich will glücklich im leben
sein wenn ich schlittschuhlaufen
vergesse ich meinen kummer und mein
schicksal
ist ein star im chinesischen fernsehen
haben sie oft seine geschichte erzählt
gerade jetzt wo die nation kurz vor
beginn der spiele ihr lächeln der welt
zeigen will er wirbt gerne für peking
und sein land
schüler und alle anderen länder freuen
sich seit so langer zeit auf olympia wir
hoffen dass die athleten auf der ganzen
welt sich gut kennen lernen und
freundschaftlich zusammen stehen
neun tage vor beginn der eröffnung der
winterspiele steigt die anspannung in
der hauptstadt die eigene olympia spur
ist eröffnet nur wer einen sonderausweis
hat darf sie benutzen das heißt noch
mehr staus als sonst aber
trotzdem spürt man bei vielen chinesen
eine vorfreude vor dem maskottchen macht
herren noch ein foto von seiner frau
beide haben noch die harten zeiten
erlebt als china arm war und sich
niemand wintersport leisten konnte
als wir jung waren war schiefer eine
sport hat für einige wenige gewesen
jetzt ist es populär man konnte früher
auch nicht schlittschuhlaufen wenn man
konnte sich die schule nicht leisten
peking ist die einzige stadt auf der
welt die bisher sommer und winterspiele
austragen durfte das zeigt wie mächtig
das land geworden ist von corona
behaupten sie keine angst zu haben nein
ich mache mir überhaupt keine sorgen
unsere regierung hat alles im griff
das ist die offizielle parole die in
china gilt aber wer genau hinschaut
spürt nervosität in der hauptstadt
massentest stationen werden aufgebaut
für den ernstfall eines großen ausbruchs
das neujahrsfest beginnt in wenigen
tagen hunderte millionen menschen wollen
ihre familien besuchen die regierung hat
sie aufgefordert nicht zu fahren damit
das virus sich nicht verbreitet wer
trotzdem fahren will braucht einen
gültigen test
die kontrollmaßnahmen variieren in
meiner stadt brauche ich nach der
ankunft keine quarantäne zu machen
mehr dürfen wir nicht fragen hören sie
auf zu filmen der chef der teststation
ermahnt die wartenden in der schlange
stellt euch in einer reihe auf seht ihr
nicht die ausländer filmen aus bevor er
dann kommt um uns zu stoppen
solche bilder wollte chinas führung
unbedingt vermeiden das virus ist nach
peking zurückgekehrt mehrere stadtteile
befinden sich im lockdown
im wan linie an haben sie die haustüren
von außen zugenagelt die nächsten wochen
kommt hier keiner raus dieses olympische
fieber will peking nicht verbreiten der
wachdienst hat uns entdeckt das heißt
das ende des filmens naht
es ist die politik chinas sie dürfen
nicht die korona maßnahmen zeigen ich
weiß nicht wie lange die quarantäne geht
das entscheiden andere ich folge nur
befehlen
in wanning yuan sind die großen
kühllager pc's die transporter stehen
bewegungslos auf dem parkplatz von hier
aus werden erst einmal keine
lebensmittel in alle teile der stadt
gefahren
das testen der gesamten bevölkerung des
stadtteils hat bereits begonnen in den
letzten zehn tagen hat es insgesamt 75
corona fälle in der hauptstadt gegeben
davon sechs omikron dies sind viele für
ein land das stolz auf seine 0 kokot
strategie ist
ich mache mir schon
china macht sich auch sorgen denn
mehrere millionen einwohner mussten in
den letzten wochen in den lock down
keiner kann sagen wie sie das
eingesperrtsein ertragen haben denn nur
chinesische journalisten dürfen
berichten und sie zeigen einen staat der
alles im griff zu haben scheint
wir haben jemanden in der 13 millionen
stadt haan gefunden der bereit ist mit
uns über ihre traumatische lockdown
erfahrung zu reden sie hat aber angst
ihr gesicht zu zeigen
deshalb versteckt sie sich hinter einem
vorhang interview mit einer gardine auch
das ist china vor den olympischen
spielen
ich habe noch nie eine geisterstadt
erlebt du kannst nicht zu lange allein
bleiben du musst doch mit jemandem reden
ich fühle mich schlecht meine stimmung
schwankt manchmal mache ich manchmal
weine ich ich hoffe die regierung
kümmert sich später um die seelischen
probleme der menschen
ist dagegen ein olympia geschichte die
china gerne zeigen will einer der kämpft
auch wenn ihnen das schicksal hart
getroffen hat
überwinde die schwierigkeiten überwinde
die unangenehmen dinge und finde etwas
was dir freude macht
skifans lebens motto klingt nach einem
olympischen geist wie gemacht für diese
verrückten corona zeit
[Musik]